حسنًا ، أليسون آه قبل بضع دقائق فقط ،
أصدرت السلطات هنا في ناشفيل مقطع فيديو بقيمة دقيقتين تقريبًا ،
يُظهر مطلق النار البالغ من العمر 28 عامًا ، آه ،
بشكل أساسي ، قادم إلى
هذه المدرسة هنا ، يُظهر الفيديو أه البالغ من العمر
28 عامًا ، وهو يطلق النار على
النافذة  من الباب الزجاجي ثم
جعلوا أنفسهم في النهاية يجعلون أنفسهم
يجعلون مطلق النار يدخل
المدرسة الآن ، يستمر فيديو المراقبة
أيضًا لإظهار أه هذا مطلق النار وهو
يتجول حول ما يبدو أنه مدخل
أه مرة واحدة داخل هذه المدرسة
يقوم مطلق النار  هل لديك نمط AR هذا اكتب
سلاحًا يمكنك رؤيته في
فيديو المراقبة ، من المهم أن
نلاحظ هنا أنه في أي وقت من الأوقات في الفيديو
الذي تم إصداره اليوم ، هل ترى أي
موظف أو أي أطفال فيه الآن
لجزء كبير من  الفيديو ،
يبدو أن مطلق النار يدخل إلى غرفة واحدة
ويقضي بعض الوقت هناك ثم يعود
للخارج مباشرةً ثم يُرى مرة
أخرى وهو يشير إلى هذا السلاح مما يجعله
ينتقل من غرفة إلى
أخرى ثم يمر في النهاية في
أحد الممرات  طوال الليل حقًا ،
كان قسم شرطة ناشفيل
ينشر صور أه للمشهد الموجود
هنا هذا الباب الأمامي للمبنى
الذي تم إطلاق النار عليه ، لذا تم
إعطاؤنا إشارة إلى أنهم
سيصدرون هذا الفيديو وهكذا فقط
قبل بضع دقائق شاركوا مقطع
الفيديو هذا مرة أخرى ، مدته حوالي دقيقتين
ويظهر أم 28 عامًا وهي
تدخل المبنى آه ،
وفقًا للسلطات ، كان مطلق النار قد
خطط له بدقة وقدر
كبير من الوقت والجهد  يبدو أنه
قد تم إنفاقه على التخطيط لهذا الهجوم
الذي يعتقدون أنه كان مستهدفًا ، ولذا
الليلة مرة أخرى ، نلقي أليسون
أول نظرة على بعض فيديوهات المراقبة
داخل المدرسة أثناء إطلاق النار هذا